rencontre au sommet de sotchi en octobre
dernier ce sont trois pays africains
l'egypte la république sud africaine et
la république démocratique du congo qui
sont les présidents de l'année dernière
le président actuel et le président
futur de l'union africaine
nous sommes liés par des relations
amicales avec l'union africaine
nous avons des relations
d'investissement ainsi que des relations
politiques et économiques et nous avons
fait preuve de notre intérêt sur tous
les volets y compris l'économie les
relations humanitaire ainsi que des
consultations politiques avec les
collègues fraikin nous avons parlé de la
coopération au sein du secrétariat forum
de partenariat russie afrique
ce secrétariat et destiné au
renforcement des contacts au niveau des
ministères des affaires étrangères mais
également avec des mécanismes de l'union
africaine et d'autres structures
d'intégration qui existent en afrique ce
secrétariat est chargé de la préparation
des nouvelles initiatives
je parlais du sommet prochain qui est
planifié prévu pour un l'année 2022
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
décidé de tenir ces sommets une fois en
trois ans nous avons parlé des
nécessités énergétique des pays
africains ce sont les nécessités et les
besoins qui sont en croissance
vu la croissance économique de l'afrique
nous avons parlé de la sécurité
énergétique des africains y compris
grâce à la coopération avec la
fédération de russie dans le domaine des
hydrocarbures
et de l'énergie nucléaire le directeur
général de roche atom à l'exil icade
geof a présenté les possibilités
conforme et le vice ministre du commerce
et de l'industrie monsieur kraus dave a
également fait sa présentation nos
collègues africains ont formulé
certaines initiatives
comment coopérer dans le domaine
économique et commercial et nous avons
parlé de ces initiatives au sein de
l'association de la coopération
économique avec les pays africains et
cette initiative comprend quelques
sociétés le russe qui sont intéressés
par la coopération avec les pays
africains seront satom transmash banques
et d'autres sociétés également c'est une
plateforme de l'assistance eurus aux
pays africains
ces sociétés sont intéressées et d'être
implantés sur le territoire de certains
pays africains et créer des structures
conformes
nous avons à accorder une attention
particulière aux questions humanitaires
surtout bien sûr il s'agit de la
répartition de la pandémie du cornât
virus ce qui a impacté beaucoup le
niveau des relations internationales
apporter une préjudice à l'économie
nationale de chaque pays et ce président
us serait peut-être plus considérable
qu'ont l'estiment actuellement nous
avons formulé des paroles de
remerciement et nous avons entendu
également des paroles de remerciement de
là
par des pays africains qui ont remercié
la russie pour l'aide dans le cadre de
la lutte contre la pandémie plus de 30
pays ont demandé de l'aide russe no
examine hausse et demande avec beaucoup
d'attention le vice-ministre de
rospotrebnadzor monsieur simoneau qui
est à parler en détail des possibilités
russe d'accorder une aide dans le cadre
de la lutte contre le coronavirus en
utilisant les structures internationales
et les structures africaines et nous
avons contribué à la réalisation de ces
initiatives dans le cadre du fonds
monétaire international de la banque
mondiale également nous avons parlé de
l'intérêt mutuels dans le cadre de la
mise au point des vaccins à en utilisant
également l'expérience de notre
coopération d'il ya quelques années dans
la lutte contre les mollahs en parlant
des questions politiques que nous avons
parlé du 60e anniversaire de la
déclaration une usine consacré à
l'indépendance de l'afrique
nous avons constaté que c'est un
document pertinent qui a mis fin au
colonialisme et à l'époque notre pays
l'union soviétique a joué un grand rôle
pour adopter cette déclaration nous
avons parlé de la vérité historique et
qui devraient être concernés et
conservait puisque certains collègues
occidentaux préfèrent actuellement de
passer sous silence
l'histoire où sont les racines des
grands problèmes de l'afrique
pour nous il serait inacceptable
d'oublier cette époque et il serait
également inacceptable de fermer les
yeux sur l'expérience néocolonialistes
et nous avons évoqué également ce
problème avec nos partenaires
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes mis
d'accord la création des nations unies
achever un grand rôle dans le processus
de décolonisation et également dans la
victoire contre le nazisme et les pays
qui est cher à réécrire l'histoire de la
seconde guerre mondiale cherche
également à oublier le passé colonial
dans l'afrique sont tombés d'accord sur
le fait que ce processus de
décolonisation n'est pas achevée et les
réalisations des nations unies les
décisions de la cour internationale
nécessite de trouver une solution je
parle par exemple d'une solution de
l'archipel des chagos et la souveraineté
de madagascar sur les îles de parent est
aussi
les de mayotte ce sont les parents qui
sont sous la tutelle française malgré
les décisions des nations unies
pour nous il est très important de
continuer les discussions dans le cadre
des nations unies il y à un comité ad'
hoc chargée de décolonisation avec nos
partenaires africains donc nous allons
accélérer les efforts pour trouver des
solutions non négociation était bien
utile
nous avons mis au point certaines
propositions pour formuler l'agenda du
sommet russie afrique en 2022 suite aux
décisions de sotchi en octobre dernier
et ce sommet aura lieu sur le territoire
africain à l'issue de notre travail nous
avons adopté une déclaration commune qui
serait diffusée parmi les journalistes
et et je vous invite de lire cette
déclaration quels sont vos questions la
chaîne arte hassan nasser je me sens
pris est merci poko bonjour monsieur le
ministre
à votre avis quels sont les commentaires
sur les situations libye il y à des
contradictions et des désaccords entre
les deux parties et les forces qui
soutiennent et c'est deux parties cela
préoccupe beaucoup
la communauté internationale moscou
réitère son attachement au dialogue
direct avec les parties belligérantes
vous avez soutenu l'initiative du caire
vous êtes pour le renforcement des
nations unies comment on pourrait
réaliser ces initiatives puisque rien ne
change
sur le terrain on peut le réaliser en
agissant d'une seule façon arrêter les
hostilités et arrêter de pousser les
détachements armés à l'est ou bien à
l'est malheureusement tous nos
partenaires ont constaté un fait évident
il n'y a pas de solution politique et au
pardon un solution militaire dans ce
conflit libyen à un moment donné quand
nous avons invité des protagonistes de
ce conflit
haftar saleh que sa rage à moscou avant
la conférence de berlin à l'armée
nationale libyenne considérer qu'elles
ont des positions très fortes sur le
terrain et il n'était pas prête à signer
un document qui pourrait être acceptable
pour monsieur sa rage maintenant l'armée
nationale libyenne est prête à signer ce
document
mais le gouvernement de tripoli ne le
veut pas jusque il mise sur la solution
militaire c'est la raison principale ce
qui se passe avec nos collègues turcs
dans le cadre du dialogue qui était
sanctionné au sommet par les présidents
russe et turc
nous essayons de concertée des approches
qui devrait permettre de procéder à un
cessez-le-feu et donc trouver des
solutions qui ont été évoqués à la
conférence de berlin et réitérées lors
de la rencontre au caire dans la
déclaration du caire c'est un grand
problème aujourd'hui et maintenant je le
répète tout récemment à moscou nous
avons parlé avec de la salers qui dirige
le parlement à tobrouk
nos continuons nos contacts avec
monsieur sa rage à tripoli et bien sûr
avec le marshall maréchal haftar qui est
à la tête de l'armée nationale libyenne
nous adressons des signaux en disant qu'
il fallait quand même procéder à un
cessez-le-feu nos collègues turcs
travaillent avec le gouvernement de
tripoli
et j'espère qu'ils vont réussir puisque
c'est une seule solution concernant le
rôle des nations unies 8 bien sûr et il
faut renforcer le rôle des nations unies
dans le conflit libyen
il ya déjà six mois le monsieur qassam
salameh est parti après la conférence de
berlin
mais pour le moment le secrétaire
général monsieur godrèche n'arrive pas à
trouver son remplaçant sa première
proposition de candidature
c'était monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères de l'algérie
cette candidature a été soutenue par
tous sauf nos collègues à des états unis
ensuite il a proposé une autre
candidature
c'est l'ancien ministre du ghana madame
t t il ya deux mois mais le secrétaire
général n'arrivent pas à adopter cette
candidature
je crois que cette possession ce
processus est freinée par les
représentants américains donc après le
départ de ghassan salem
cette mission est pré citées par le
président par intérim
ce président par intérim et c'est une
citoyenne des états unis mais je ne
voudrais pas que les états unis
entravent cette désignation
en espérant que leurs concitoyennes va
peut-être mener la politique qui serait
une politique américaine et je crois que
et j'espère que le secrétaire général va
arriver quand même à trouver une
solution et je suis persuadé que ce
serait un représentant de l'union
africaine qui qui devrait être le
précédent agents cette oscar où
véronique adès nos couvents je vous en
prie j'ai pas entendu votre question
malheureusement maintenant est-ce que
vous m'entendez est ce que vous pourriez
commenter le rapport de la commission
des nations unies qui parle des frappes
des avions russes comme un crime de
guerre
c'est une commission indépendante
chargée de l'enquète des crimes de
guerre en syrie cette commission a été
créée non pas par décision de consensus
le mandat de cette commission suscite
beaucoup de questions et les méthodes de
travail
aussi la décision de créer cette
commission a été adopté par des pays
occidentaux qui voudrait changer le
régime politique en syrie et donc ils
sont mis au point un mécanisme qui est
chargé de rechercher des compromis et
compromet des informations mensongères
cette commission n'a pas trouvé la
possibilité de visiter damas est donc
cette commission indépendante
utilisez des faits qui les trouvent dans
des réseaux sociaux des il utilise des
sources anonymes un il se réfère à la
sécurité ce sont les méthodes utilisées
par à l'organisation l'interdiction des
armes chimiques
ils essaient actuellement de faire
adopter une résolution à la base d'un
rapport qui était rédigée en violation
de la charte d'interdiction des armes
chimiques
ce sont donc les noms et des partenaires
qui restent anonymes et il parle
toujours des problèmes de sécurité
nous partons du fait de la nécessité
exclusive de trouver des solutions dans
une crise syrienne à la base des faits
concrets et des renseignements fiables
cette commission indépendante n'est pas
responsable de cette déclaration et cela
a été prouvé aussi à segodnia
ivan boulatov un bonjour monsieur le
ministre de questions
le chef du pentagone a déclaré que le
ministère de la défense a retenu et ses
adversaires moscow et québec avec 1 le
gouvernement ukrainien a décidé de
sortir de ce le protocole du protocole
de 2013 qui parle de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
quels sont vos commentaires là dessus 1
concernant la déclaration de marque
espère je ne sais pas qu'est ce que je
voudrais dire là dessus puisque si
monsieur espère estime que la mission du
ministère de la défense
c'est la retenue de la russie et de la
chine
c'est la philosophie donc de
l'administration américaine qui voudrait
retenir tout le monde partout dans le
monde sauf sa propre liberté ils veulent
avoir une liberté de faire n'importe
quoi et en toute impunité
je parle par exemple de l'accord du ciel
ouvert du
traité est fini je parle également
d'autres traités internationaux et c'est
déplorable puisque à mon avis ministère
de la défense comme on dit les
militaires sont plus prudents que les
hommes politiques puisqu'ils savent très
bien ce que c'est la guerre mais cette
philosophie que nous observons de la
part du chef du pentagone est très
déplorable nous le regrettons beaucoup
puisque nous misons sur le développement
des relations paisibles y compris bien
sûr avec les états unis et les contacts
que monsieur espère a eu avec le
ministre russe de la défense
mais sur ce coup je ne peux pas
commenter ces conversations mais cette
conversation était tout à fait
constructive et je crois que tout pays
sur cette planète va se poser une
mission non pas retenir quelqu'un mais
garantir la stabilité stratégique tout
en respectant les intérêts de tous les
pays y compris les grands pays quand
nous menons un dialogue avec les
américains nous voyons que il voterait
oublier le terme la stabilité
stratégique mais parlez plutôt de la
confrontation stratégiques c'est-à-dire
que se prépare au conflit en n'importe
quel pays qui pourraient défendre leurs
propres intérêts c'est très mal et c'est
très mal pour les etats unis eux mêmes
bien sûr on peut parler d certaines
menaces de la part de la russie au bien
de la chine mais c'est une méthode de
divertir faire oublier les problèmes qui
existent sur le territoire des
etats-unis s'agit bien sûr de la
campagne électorale et tout cela va être
fait grâce à cette liberté d'action et
l'oubli des méthodes de freins et de
contrepoids le président poutine a
proposé des efforts dans le cadre des
nations unies pour la stabilité
stratégique concernant le cren j'ai pas
entendu que nos voisins et craignent un
vote sortir dieu
meira mémorandum de coopération contre
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme et
ils ont sorti de beaucoup de forums
internationaux
c'est leur liberté de faire mais je vois
que leur manière de faire c'est leur
droit si ils s'estiment que ainsi ils
vont défendre leurs intérêts nationaux
dans ce cas soit ce qui est clair c'est
que la lutte contre le terrorisme ne
doit pas être l'otage des jeux
géopolitiques mais je crois que les
autorités craignaient ne maintenant mène
justement des jeux géopolitiques la
déclaration monsieur président zelensky
par exemple concernant les accords de
minsk qui sont destinés au maintien des
sanctions occidentales contre moscow ca
c
le droit des ukrainiens nous continuons
des contacts dans le cadre du format de
normandie tout récemment nous avons tenu
une rencontre des conseillers et ceux
qui a confirmé que la partie écrit
vienne ne veut pas confirmer leur son
engagement dans l'es4 du format anormaux
dit et nous entendons de la france et de
l'allemagne en tant que partie prenante
du dialogue de normandie d'assumer leurs
responsabilités puisque kiev viole ses
engagements dans le cadre du complexe de
paix de minsk quotidien kommersant
mariana belenkaya bonjour j'ai deux
questions pour rebondir dans la question
de hassan est ce que il y a une chance
d'arrêter les hostilités en libye et en
arrière on parlait des frappes à alger
fera par exemple est-ce que la russie
est prête de jouer l'intermédiaire
autour du barrage renaissance
je ne sais pas s'il ya une chance de
cessez-le-feu en libye
il ya toujours une chance mais est ce
qu'ils vont utiliser ses chances je ne
sais pas de toute façon
il ya six mois à 700 c'est exister deux
ou trois ou quatre ans il y avait une
chance puisqu'il y avait des conférences
de paris de palerme et abu dhabi y avait
une conférence de berlin il y a 6 mois
il ya eu une rencontre à moscou il ya vu
un document d'une page et demie sur le
cessez le feu
ils n'ont pas saisi cette chance
actuellement une autre partie ne veut
pas saisir cette chance mais cette
chance et maintenir toujours cette
chance est une alternance est une
solution qui n'a pas d'alternative
si on veut quand même voir la baisse
instaurée en libye situation dans ce
conflit sur le terrain quels sont les
mouvements des parties belligérantes
c'est secondaire
nous sommes d'accord il n'y a pas de
solution armée il faut donc arrêter les
hostilités
il ya un comité militaire 5.5 il ya une
proposition qui est réitérée par une
déclaration de duke r 1
il ya une initiative de monsieur salaire
qui est vient de visiter moscou c'est à
dire la formation des organismes
collectif sur le pied d'égalité qui vont
réunir les intérêts des trois régions
historiques de libye c'est une
initiative très raisonnables concernant
ce conflit entre l'egypte le soudan
l'ethiopie aps autour du barrage
renaissance
qui est construit par l'ethiopie dans la
région du nil bleu nous avons proposé
aux parties prenantes du conflit notre
assistance technique puisque il ya des
choses que la russie pourrait faire les
etats unis ont proposé également leur
aide
il ya eu plusieurs rencontres sur le
territoire des états unis et nous avons
salué ce progrès je crois que maintenant
les parties des trois parties se sont
convenues de à renforcer les contacts au
niveau des ministres en charge de ce
dossier ce dossier a été discuté au sein
des nations unies et nous avons demandé
les trois parties de trouver une
solution sur la base des normes du droit
international et bien sûr sur la base de
la prise en compte des intérêts de
chaque pays qui est partie prenante de
ce conflit autour du barrage de la
renaissance
merci beaucoup et à la prochaine
merci merci et au revoir